se former aux métiers de la santé assis
derrière une table ce n'est plus
d'actualité en tout cas certainement pas
du côté du centre de formation de la
croix rouge à chambray-lès-tours là-bas
22 salles de classe ont été aménagés
pour reproduire le plus fidèlement
possible une chambre d'hôpital où
l'intérieur d'une maison d'un
particulier des mannequins peuvent à
tout moment faire un arrêt cardiaque et
tout est filmé pour ensuite être
analysés par des professeurs visite
guidée de cet équipement exceptionnel
avec rémy carton dans sa chambre
d'hôpital philippe supporte mal
l'hospitalisation opéré des ligaments
croisés il insiste auprès du personnel
pour sortir vous ne remarquez rien qui
cloche
car tout ceci est faux philippe du lin
est acteur il participe à une mise en
scène pour former les futurs infirmiers
travaillent détracteurs c'est dans ce
contexte là c'est de jouer le scénario
qui nous est donnée par les
professionnels psychologues de façon à
jouer les caractéristiques de la
pathologie physique morale psychologique
si nous ne sommes pas à l'hôpital mais
dans le centre de simulation flambant
neuf de la croix rouge
cette étudiante apprend à faire une
perfusion sa tenue et son matériel sont
bien réels seul le bras du patient est
factice ça me permet de dédramatiser le
soin finalement j'arrive en stage
j'arrive auprès du patient je sais que
j'ai à faire je visualise mon front et
du cou je suis plus à l'aise et je pense
que ça se ressent dans la dans la
relation avec le patient aussi
finalement les simulations sont filmés
par des caméras piloter en régie les
scènes sont ensuite débriefer en cours
avec des mannequins et des acteurs les
formateurs immerge les étudiants dans
des situations réalistes pour s'assurer
qu'ils auront les bonnes attitudes sur
le terrain on prépare l'individu donc ce
qui fait que il n'aura pas cet effet de
surprise une fois en stage ou oran poste
puisque ce sera des choses qui n'aura
déjà rencontré vécu donc ça ça lui
permettra de 2 comme le disent certains
étudiants d'être en sécurité
bonjour ah oui c'était le rendez-vous de
ce matin vous en prie entrée à côté du
faux hôpital il ya aussi des
appartements témoins ici on forme les
futurs ergothérapeute a travaillé chez
le patient
on y fait également appel à des acteurs
pour entraîner des étudiants aux
situations sociales difficiles
près de deux cent mille euros ont été
investis dans ce centre de simulation le
plus grand de france à tours on répète
avant de travailler car une santé de
qualité ne s'improvise pas